[Music]
here we go again june's playstation plus
games have been announced and it's a
pretty stacked month you can play the
following games from the first tuesday
of the month which is june the 7th so
let's do this what a game to start with
god of war one of the greatest games
ever made god of war 2018 combined
brutal action and incredibly heartfelt
moments between a father and son getting
to grips with the loss of their wife and
mother our 25-hour mission is simple to
scatter her ashes as per her final
request yet that becomes a road of
action puzzles and amazing set-pieces
kratos has traveled from greek mythology
into the north world and that presence
here brings attention from the gods
including the sons of thor kratos wields
an axe this time named leviathan with
the awesome ability to return it to his
hand at will this weapon feels
phenomenal for the entire duration of
the game leviathan can be upgraded and
adapted to have stat boosts to give
kratos the edge in battle this is true
of the armor sets too the sheer size and
scale of the boss fights you'll
encounter are breathtaking from trolls
and dragons to the challenging battles
with valkyries god of war received
countless 10 out of 10 review scores so
if you haven't played it yet you really
should and if you have played it before
now is a great time to relive it as the
sequel ragnarok is coming sooner than
you think god of war without a doubt is
a masterpiece game two is nickelodeon or
star brawl a platform fighter which is
pretty much a super smash bros clone the
change being the characters nickelodeon
delves into its archives of hit tv shows
to bring together people like spongebob
and leonardo from the teenage mutant
ninja turtles beat the living daylights
out of each other until everyone except
you is yeated from the platform on the
plus side the speed of all style brawl
feels much quicker than the most recent
smash bros titles and there's a ton of
easter eggs and nods for nick fans to
spot in each stage if you have enough
time to look at them that is but sadly
the negatives do outweigh the pros the
character models are low quality the
voice acting is non-existent in most
cases making beloved characters feel
vacant and there isn't much to do
outside of the bare bones solo arcade
mode and playing four player multiplayer
when your friends come round reviews
average out at six out of ten and if i'm
honest unless you love nickelodeon i'd
recommend that you wait for the free to
play multiverses game which has an open
beta next month game three is another
brawler this time set in the world of
naruto if you say naruto or naruto it's
fine let's not have any hate please
naruto
shinobi striker is a multiplayer game
setting four shinobis against another
set of four shinobi step one is to
create your very own fighter customizing
as you go gameplay includes more than
just fighting mobility is key with wall
running and ziplining just as important
as the combat itself when the fights
begin shinobi striker wants us to
combine different fighting styles to
form combos these can be confusing as
mastering ranged abilities and defensive
plays and standard attacks can take time
to learn constant slow improvement is
what shinobi striker offers a great
element which keeps you coming back are
those unlocks taking part in mission
mode will see new masters appear who
then offer you new abilities to improve
your fighting style naruto tubaruto
shinobi strikeout reviews at six out of
ten will you try it oh and game four is
a reminder that you have less than two
weeks from the day this video releases
to download gta online for free on ps5
the ability for ps4 owners to add it
through the app has been removed which
seems a little unfair but that's the
gaming industry so if you have a ps5
this is your last chance to download gta
online for free so what you're playing
this month please review the games in
the comments below and i'll see you
again next month